everybody it's Mike from Immortal flows
and welcome to today's video and today
is Thursday December 22nd uh 2022 just
ahead of the Christmas holidays and you
know the markets had uh been selling off
all day so you know what I want to talk
about is you know trying to identify a
low using the order flow you know order
flow is not about uh predicting where a
low is going to come in but rather
reacting to what you're seeing in the
order Flow To You Know confidently buy
off of that low
and you know like I said today was a
great uh example of a market just you
know selling off all day you know once
the cash opened up we eventually found
our load just after 12 30 here and then
we rallied you know from 88 and a
quarter I'm sorry 88 and a half all the
way up to you know to around the 46 and
46 and a half level uh going into the
close so it was you know we sold off you
know from the cash so we sold up about
80 90 points and then we recovered back
about half of that move down and
you know it was interesting because you
know after the market closed uh the
president came out and you know tweeted
about how great our economy is doing
um you know I mean
Market just sold off you know quite
nicely even though there was a late
recovery so again you know take these
economic numbers that come out with uh
with a grain of salt all right because
you know numbers can always be adjusted
and
um you know made to look nicer than they
really are again I'm not going to get
into the number I'm going to talk about
order flow now on ninjatrader okay if
you don't if you're not using it you
know you should just really quick here
um I'll just show you on the simple bar
chart there are indicators on here to
plot the current day open high low close
you just open up your indicator
box and you scroll down to the Seas look
for current day open high low close
that's what's going to put this red line
in for the low you can see the current
low is going to be red the open would be
this uh well what color they call that
Goldenrod which kind of a yellow and the
high would be green
so you know we're the high you know this
was the open and that was the high and
it's a nice reference point you can
actually also put the previous day's
open high low close on there if you like
you just scroll down that's uh named
differently it's called
prior day open high low close if you
want to see that then again the
difference is going to be instead of a
set of this uh Dash I believe it's going
to be it's going to be a hash so Square
Dash whereas the prior day is going to
be a hash and a Dash and
again you know I use the current day I
used to use the prior days but um you
know I've sort of advanced my trading
that I'm not really Keen Keen in on
yesterday's highs and lows but you still
can right there's still important
references you know because when a high
or a low is made
there's usually a reason for it right
but order flow Traders you know we're
just looking for at you know how the
order flow comes in once the market
trades a new low you know when a market
is selling off we want to know can I be
buying in here or not can I be buying in
here because if we can't be buying you
know if there's no reason to be buying
there's probably a reason to still be
selling and if you still can catch the
move down a further move down you know
that's going to be in your favor but if
something in the order flow is giving
off some bullish signals at the same
time you know you want to be aware of
that right so you can take advantage of
it because
you know oftentimes the market is going
to find a low and then rally and if you
could catch this rally I mean you know
this is this is a tremendous Rally from
you know we'll just call it you know off
this low 37 you know call it 91 92 even
if you just caught it from 92 up to 22
that's still a 30 point move you know so
trying to catch a move off of a low can
give you some good opportunities but at
first you got to be able to recognize
that the low is going to be made
okay so let's uh dive into the footprint
and you know again basic trading 101
a low is support right that should be
basic common knowledge and I'm sure
people will argue with me because you
know honestly if it wasn't support the
market would have kept dropping further
and you know Market's always looking for
a balance between supply and demand you
know when an area of the market has too
much Supply prices
drop until demand
comes in basically right that that's the
definition of spy and demand now so
let's just go back to
you know basically the cash open and
boom once the cash opened you know it's
8 30 we're just basically going sideways
here for you know the 15 minutes before
the cash open the cash open and selling
immediately came in right we saw that
big push down nice stack selling balance
we keep making new lows this is our
first sign here at 58 and a quarter
coming in here
uh potentially some maybe potentially
some buying coming in you know what was
interesting is off this cash open a nice
strong negative Delta but you know still
strong negative Delta 1300 so three and
a thousand four hundred ninety negative
Delta the next one minus 1354. here's
just minus 144 you know the market did
turn around and starting to trade up I
mean at one point the Delta was quite
strong negative is minus 861 but again
it's still a little bit less than what
you're seeing before minus thirty six
hundred minus thirteen hundred is minus
861. maybe you know maybe this Market
was going to bounce
but you still got to watch what's
happening off the Overflow you're not
going to buy the bounce off of one green
candle
right and people say well you know
Candlestick guys you know that's your
PIN bar you know people know I I attack
pin bars a lot and you know because you
know when they work you know everyone is
up there raising their hand up in the
air see I picked the low be like this is
a the pin bar right the hammer formation
well it didn't work okay Market just
went inside when a market goes inside
after you're pushing down to a new low
that's usually a sign that this
um Market isn't going to Rally I don't
want to say he's going to make a new low
but it's generally you know a market
that's
it's still undecided on on which way it
wants to go right if if this Market was
going to start to Rally you're going to
look for it to start moving up away from
that low not just sort of hang around
and go inside so we start making some
new lows in here then we get here at 8
37 potentially another you know is
another opportunity to buy you know we
Market did sort of reverse here
next bar opened up you know you got one
two three imbalances you got a nice
strong positive Delta you know this is
your first you know real strong positive
Delta since after the cash opened
um 1400 I mean the strongest since you
know the cash open was you know 415. so
it's decent right you got the aggressive
buying coming in all right next bar okay
can we build off of that
it starts to go up a little bit it goes
up
um you know the high of this bar was 62
and three quarters you know we get the
three three and a quarter three and a
half and then it reverses the aggressive
selling comes back in so again you know
this was showing some signs of
potentially being bullish right coming
up off the slow
but then it comes right back down strong
selling
one two three four five selling
imbalances strong negative Delta you
could almost forget about moving higher
right now right because while this was
kind of encouraging
he got no more follow-through coming
through right instead you're seeing
strong negative Delta then obviously in
the next bar
more selling imbalances a nice big
strong negative Delta 1238
and you know there was no Max Delta in
there zero
and it stacks on it balanced in there as
well and then we just break out to new
lows okay so you know any reason for
getting long is quickly dashed by this
red candle right here I mean even if you
got long off of this you know say you
bought it up here at 50 sorry at 63 and
a half at the high of this red Candle by
the close of this red candle you should
be getting out already okay why well
here you've got two point controls side
by side and you know it was acting
support in the next bar
so by the time this bar trades back into
it gets through it it chances are it's
going to keep going right because it's
going to follow that momentum instead of
having momentum up it's reversed you got
momentum down and Market made that new
low
now it came down here new low new low
then you know a green candle here you
know a red candle with positive Delta
which you know is indicative of
um
the aggressive buying you know in this
bar let's open this bar up a little bit
because the more volume is traded on the
offer side you can see the the 411 here
um you know the 374 the the 453 here so
there is volume being traded on the
offer but what's that telling you even
though you have nice positive Delta
right it's a red candle price action is
down so I know there's still Supply
coming into that market
okay so even though we're at the low
we've got the red candle with the
Positive Delta which is a sign of Supply
still coming in
okay I mean just because you got the one
green bar here with nice positive Delta
other than that there's really no reason
to be looking to get long and instead
you're seeing Supply come into the
market and you make a new low
I come into 845 get another new low at
age 46. you got one green candle two
bind imbalances positive Delta next bar
positive Delta
and it's starting to go up okay yeah
maybe but again it's not
is it the way it's forming in this Delta
yeah it's positive Delta it's kind of
growing but if you're sort of looking at
you know the internals of the delta
you know it's 571 versus 438 so it's a
little bit weaker but again I'm not
going to split hairs and say well it's
weaker you know you can't really you
know do anything
um if I'm looking at the max Deltas
again they're kind of equal but there is
obviously a drop off in here from the
max Delta where the final Delta again
not necessarily a sign that you know
that this move is not going to happen it
could very well happen you know but you
still want to you know wait look at the
next bar for potential confirmation one
way or the other
and next bar doesn't go any higher it
trades lower trades below this point of
control strong negative Delta
no Max Delta
again you know even though you got the
positive Deltas here you got a couple
imbalances in this bar one in this bar
it's nothing really overwhelming you
know telling you that you know what
this could be a buying opportunity
okay
so you have that in the back your head
and then again next bar red comes in
trades lower doesn't you know get past
the high of this bar at uh 57 and three
quarters then it gets it just starts
drifting lower drifting sideways again
no reason to be getting long in here
it's just you know doing nothing and
again you know if you're trying to buy a
low the markets just start to move
sooner rather than later
um you know that doesn't mean that it
can't draw out like this then eventually
10 minutes later start to Rally but
again you know if you're trying to buy
this low you're looking for the move to
to happen sooner rather than later
because you know as you sort of get
farther away if you're trying to buy off
this these two green bars and you're
still here 10 minutes later at basically
where you got in you know sort of the
reason for it is it's kind of worn off
already then the selling comes back in
and came in very fast and we dropped two
new lows whoops not only that but it
happened very fast I mean you drop the
new lows and you just kept dropping you
know basically you know close to another
10 points pretty quick I mean this low
is 51 we dropped down to 43 so about uh
was that about eight points seven or
eight points and then again no reason to
be buying in here yet right you're just
seeing one green candle and again you
know sometimes what these green candles
are after you have the sell-off is just
people you know they could be just
covering their shorts
all right that's all you know the market
sold off quite nicely it's bouncing a
little bit yeah you know off the slow 43
and a half yeah I want to lock in some
profits because they were short up here
you know at 53 and a half 54 and a half
it's a great opportunity to take profits
right but it doesn't mean that the
selling is over right and as you can see
here just sort of goes sideways again no
reason to be getting long just because
you got a couple of green candles
doesn't mean the move is over
all right could just simply be profit
taking from
the shorts from earlier and again
Market just keeps going down down now
this was interesting here at this 915
bar
because at 9 15 here all right you've
got a nice big positive Delta 602 it's
sort of right around its Max Delta of
um 604
okay that's why it's called the cyan and
next bar up all right nice again nice
positive Delta is building off of it
okay then the next bar goes inside okay
potential
move there
but what what do you see developing okay
you still got to watch what's happening
here in the order flow okay and again
nice positive Delta 755 so you got 600
okay one red candle but then 755
okay it's that's encouraging right the
buyers are finally stepping in at this
3834 area I'll show you well more like
38 39 this area that the low is four and
three quarters
okay potentially you know what we can
start maybe this is going to be our low
okay so you still got you gotta be
watching then you know what's happening
in the order flow
okay you got you know this kind of doji
candle opens and closed at the same
price Delta's gotten smaller now so you
went from 755 down to just 46 down to
49.
okay
you know you're not really building off
of it right you're just sort of hanging
around and again when you sort of see
these smallish Deltas you know like
around 50 more or less on the e-minis
um you know it's basically just telling
you that that trade is evenly matched
right buyers and sellers are evenly
matched
um then you get another green candle
here you break out to the sort of this
new little high of this move up off this
low
nice positive Delta 263. okay this is it
you know you're rubbing your hands
together you know what this Mark is
about to take off and what happens
lower
all right it doesn't go anywhere you got
the red candle down negative Delta
next candle down negative Delta when it
controls moving lower right they're not
moving sideways they're moving lower
okay so what you thought was this move
isn't really materializing right after a
couple of bars you should be able to
recognize that hey you know what this
move isn't happening
we're getting the selling coming back in
here
um you know lower point of control on
this bar then sort of Pops back up here
doji candle and then again Lower
right lower opponent control but it's
green can helping always green candle
you know maybe you should stay in the
straight no you know what you're looking
for this move already to happen you know
anywhere between you know 41 and this
high up here at three and a quarter
and it's not making that move it's just
going lower lower that's your sign to
take your loss right this move's not
happening yet
okay because you should be once you sort
of make the new high the new high the
new high off this low
and then you're just making lower high
lower high lower High
um that's not what you want to see When
You're Expecting The Market to keep
going up right you can obviously lower
opponent controls as well is is not a
good sign but it's just more or less
going sideways so even if you're getting
long and you're still in this trade I
God forbid you have your stop way down
here below this low at four and three
quarters you know you got a little stop
at 34 just below the low and you're long
from up here almost 10 points higher
cut it take your take you know cut it
now don't wait for it to come stop you
out because it's not it's not moving in
that direction and then we do make those
um new lows
okay and then you just sort of hang
around right you got the new law on the
red candle next candle inside it's an
inside bar and even though it's green
it's still inside
um that's not necessarily a good sign
right you'd want it to start moving away
from the low not sort of go inside on
the low bar
then another new low here 941
942 you know we sort of reverse back up
another green candle nice strong
positive Delta 789 so you made a new low
by you know by about a point
you pair up this bottom nice positive
Delta and another nice positive Delta
okay maybe we can finally start to move
right that's what you should be looking
for you know again anytime you're off
the low especially on a move that's
sharp right going down
you know you're going to need some sort
of confirmation that you know this is it
this could be the low and then you just
contract on the Delta to negative 48 so
you went from 789 to 546 to minus 48 not
the best sign in the world but you know
maybe this Mark is going to go sideways
and it's going to reverse and start to
trade higher then you get another inside
bar here all right negative Delta
stronger
point of control at the same level right
so it's it's not moving up it's not
necessarily moving down so it's not
really giving you any signs you know one
way or the other is it's just positive
move or negative
um and then it goes lower here
you know so you you got this three bar
of bearish information right you got the
silent balances here the two-pointed
controls and you're trading lower then
it sort of bounces up here and sort of
gives you this this fake that hey you
know what this is it we're going to go
up you know he's got to be wary of these
moves
um you know the 435 positive Delta the
you know I'd be looking for like maybe
one more bar to go a little bit higher
or sideways and then for the market to
fall over it played out you know a
little bit higher then you went sideways
and then you started to fall back down
right because what you're going to
really look for is
um you know nice consecutive bars up and
you're starting to get you know you got
one two three but then just went inside
then you failed to take out this High
here and again Delta you know the bars
are kind of mixed honestly you got two
negative three positive two negative
um and then you're back sort of down you
know near your low again you sort of
break down make a new low
at this low here
you got the negative Delta minus 348 and
again you got some support here right
you got the negative Delta on the green
candle
um and Mark starts to go up a little bit
pulls back you know get the red candle
then it goes back up a nice green candle
up the green candle up okay maybe this
is it right Delta is moving in the right
direction you know 166 482
okay maybe this is it right then you get
the bar with multiple imbalances stack
buying and balance
yeah I you know if I'm looking at this
for me it's all systems go but I'd be
only be interested in getting long above
the high of this bar right because
everything's moving in that direction
but it's not really not until you get to
this bar here that it really starts to
look bullish because with off of this no
for me that's not enough bullish
information yeah I've got one two three
binding balances over these three bars
um I do have positive Delta pointed
controls are going higher but it's
really just sort of lacking you know any
strong thing the strong thing comes in
here with the stack behind and balance
the multiple imbalance and again the
nice positive Delta
but you still gotta wait for the bar to
close right people always ask me why do
you wait till the particles because you
know I want to make sure it's going to
stay that way then how do I get long is
okay I've finally got my Catalyst here I
drop a buy stop up here at 38 because I
still want this Market to be moving in
that direction you just drop your buy
stop in there at 38 because if this is
really bullish and finally other Traders
are stepping into the market to also get
long the Market's going to keep going
but then it just goes inside
it's like finally I got my my sign of a
market that's ready to move and it just
goes inside that's not the sign you're
looking for
okay but again it's just one bar you
know I'm still sitting up here to stop
at 38 if we can get
going in that direction so maybe in the
next bar
what happens to the next bar
lower I mean lower than this bar but
again it's still inside of this first
bar after that forget about it you know
I I just I literally expect the move to
happen within two bars
and
it just keeps going down down down
new lows
right then again you see some signs of
buying coming in here with these
positive Deltas again we're closing up
near our Max Delta which is encouraging
you know but you know point of controls
a little bit higher
okay
but again it's nothing overly strong
standing out even though it's positive
Deltas yeah okay but it's only 388 257
238 sort of going in the wrong direction
right what you want to be seeing is you
know maybe the 238 here and the 388 here
you want to see this the Delta getting
stronger in a directional way even
though here it's positive it's it's
getting weaker directionally right which
is not a good sign you know 726 coming
in here is a nice sign and you sort of
build off of it here you go two ticks up
then you just go inside and just go
sideways you know which is not a good
sign again if you're getting long in
here say you bought this high at 36
thinking this Market's going up and it
just goes inside by time you get to this
bar you know you should be looking to
get out you know it did give you sort of
a chance to you know get out I don't say
it break even but you know with with a
smaller loss I mean you still would have
taken a loss have you gotten along but
again you know when you're trying to buy
a low foreign
you're often going to find yourself
getting stopped out right because
a market can still keep it making lows
but you're
RR is you know potentially greater right
today we rallied off the low
50 points
right so if you're risking you know two
three four points but your potential
reward is 20 30 40 points you should
have no problem with that
okay and it just sort of goes sideways
sideways and then finally breaks down to
new lows okay and again we made these
new lows here
this is around 10 10 40 and you know
even though we're just sort of hanging
around this low right the low of 23 and
a quarter rally up come back down Trade
It Trade It Again trade it again okay
every time we come down to it we're
trading you know a little bit less
volume well here's 55 then 44 24.
you know so it's decreasing here okay
you know maybe this the selling is
starting to wear off
we are getting some positive Deltas but
again it's not really going anywhere
it's just going sideways you know one of
the ways to just really I mean if you
can't tell this Market is going sideways
look at the points of control they're
all sort of around the same level you
know around this 25 you gotta do a
little bit lower two at 25 one at 25 and
order another one at 25 and a quarter
and it's just again there's no really
standout reason to be getting long in
here right and you're just sort of going
sideways it looks like it's finally
starting to pull up then the selling
comes back in
make new lows here okay and just keep
going down now this move here was quite
strong obviously strong negative Deltas
there's absolutely no reason to be
buying on this move down
again go sideways but again no reason to
be buying in here nothing
in terms of order flow
and then you know 1143 make a new low I
mean we just make a new lows from 11 35
to 11 43. start to Rally back a little
bit okay
but again it's not much of a rally you
know you're talking the low from O2
you're rallying up to 07 that that's not
a rally that's only five points
but again not really anything strong in
terms of you know aggressive buying you
know here you got one buying a balance
but here you got one two three
okay you know here you got four
but the Deltas you know it's still kind
of that strong right 400 okay but again
336 you know 200 200 you know again if
you're gonna start to pull off the low
you want to see some strong Deltas 800
700.
a thousand
you know like like here this is the only
111 128. now granted you know volume is
they were coming into lunchtime 11 50 so
volumes are a little bit lighter
so do you think the volume the Market's
going to make a big move on light volume
probably not
all right then we start making new lows
again
so it's not really any reason to buy
I want I don't want to get into the
whole you know reason to get short again
but you know generally if you don't have
a reason to buy you could either just
stay out of the market or get short but
you probably want to just simply keep it
simple and stay out of the market rather
than trying to get too fancy on stuff
and then um you know around 12
just after 12 this is um you know what
time is this 12 10. we made this new low
37.93 we broke 3 800 and we're trading
down here 38 37 93
you got the green I'm sorry the the red
candle with positive Delta y's because
you had some Supply in here coming in at
this
um 3796 you got imbalance
and then the green candle right nice
positive Delta 600 we got past that area
of Supply so it's probably not there
anymore at least now and you're starting
to move away from that which is good
right nice candle up nice positive Delta
but again you got this positive Delta
607 and here's just 458 okay it's still
strong but it's not
stronger than the previous bar I would
like to see it as strong as or stronger
than the previous bar
yeah you got some bind and balances
point of control is going up
and then you get this bar here Delta
smaller 292 so it's actually around half
of what the previous bar was a little
more than a little less than half rather
okay
why isn't this bar going up more you
know volume is decent it's 2300
contracts
but Delta's only 292 you know you you'd
want something you know maybe a little
bit more price movement
um you know maybe a trade up to 3 800
not just sort of a compact bar with
small Delta
because again you're looking for it to
build off of this
and you know it's not really building
off of it but again I mean you know
maybe you're getting you know you're
thinking of getting long at 3 800. okay
you're dropping a buy stop there
um 3 800
and it does pop up a little bit up to oh
one and a quarter
and then it's just not building off of
it I don't like that you're going up on
declining Delta off of the low of the
day you'd want to be going up off of you
know more positive Delta in the sense of
it getting a little stronger over time
not getting weaker than turning negative
even though here's a nice positive Delta
651 yeah okay again you know you're
really already getting long around 99
or you know even 99 and a half
for a move higher then again you're not
Delta is 293 but you you'd want it to be
even stronger than 293.
and then it comes in with a stronger
negative Delta 500 so you'll basically
forget about it it's not moving that's
your sign okay just cut this one
right because you're not getting that
movement the Delta is not really giving
you that sign right Delta is the the
sign of aggressive
um trading that's taking place and then
you know you get that bar here again
sort of that the aggressive buying
coming in positive Delta 236 stack
behind and balance okay but if you're
not already out you know in this bar
maybe it's giving you second hope
okay but you still need it to be moving
and then the next bar is a red candle
small Delta of 65 and it closes on its
low
okay so you had hope here
don't give it too much hope
let it happen right if it's not going to
happen very quick
it's probably not going to happen
anymore and you can see it just goes
lower
so if
you're not stop I'm sorry if you didn't
bail out already that's your sign
already by this bar don't let it come
down here to a new low to stop you out
it should be realizing this move is not
happening and cut your loss right that's
where reading the order flow
is going to help you by realizing I
don't have that buying coming in here
anymore it's time for me to cut it and
then you just sort of go sideways here
before you eventually break down to a
new low new low new low
okay then you get down here this is uh
12 34.
okay you're coming down coming in hot
right minus a thousand in the Delta 11
13.
then small Delta 39 which is basically
neutral then 234 500.
at the low same low right you're trading
less volume one
big positive Delta 766.
okay great you know we're at the low of
the day now we've got nice positive
Delta
then the next bar goes inside
the fish right
small Delta three
but the next bar is a bit more
encouraging 400 okay see it's 700 400
okay it's sort of going you know not
it's not building in the sense of you
know
800 or 900 but it's still a decent
number because this number is quite
strong 766.
I mean if you're looking at these
positive Deltas from earlier it's your
strongest one in in quite a while
um then here again you you've got 271
again not a strong number it's not 700
800 900 but again it's closing near our
Max which is again okay you've seen a
couple buying imbalances here you've got
the selling and balances telling you
that there's some support coming into
the market
so you got aggressive buying you know
off the slow you got one two here one
here one two here two here one here
then you get to this bar right well this
Delta here and this one is 394. okay so
it's it's back up to a respectable
number 394 so it's higher than this 271.
again it's close to the 402.
okay wait for the next bar
if you're still not convinced all right
again you don't have to pull the trigger
early
let the market speak to you
then here nice positive Delta 876 you
got one two three four bind imbalances
in here again you can see off this low
well this is these two bars are the same
low
but you're moving higher with the points
of control over one two three and even
in this fourth bar so by now you should
be saying you know what maybe this is
going to be
um the move that I've been waiting for
right and again you know maybe you're
still not convinced you say well you
know what the high of this bar is seven
and a quarter I could get long seven and
three quarters just drop a buy stop in
there let the market get you into the
position okay
and draw the line here
seven and three quarters you just wait
for the market to come in but it should
come in sooner rather than later
right it should be coming in either the
next bar or the next bar I like to give
it two bars next bar comes in goes
inside
okay that doesn't mean that the reason
for the trade is over
then finally you know it gets you in on
the second bar
and then the next bar breaks higher
finally um you know from seven and three
quarters all the way up to
um nine and it's again then you go
inside then again you sort of testing
that high go up a little bit
and then it's starting to go sideways
okay it's like darn you know hey you're
trying to buy this low and it's just
going sideways pulls back but it sort of
pulls back to this area in here you know
96 and a half
again even though you got you know these
red candles it's not overly negative in
the sense of you know strong negative
Deltas you know 34 190 positive 166 on
the red candle 280. again it is sort of
getting up to that area you know to you
know in the 200s 300 400 that I'd really
start to worry
and again it's just sort of hanging
around there hanging around but again
reason you're getting long is off of
this candle and these three candles in
here
but at the same time you're not really
seeing anything bearish and just sort of
hanging around again you know your entry
is this seven and uh three quarters
and you know it does dip down to five
and a quarter
and back up to your entry price so
you're sort of trading around it now
again it's like ah you know you got long
in here 12 42 it's you're about 10
minutes into the trade
you're just hanging around break even
when you trade back up to break even
then you sort of come back down it this
is the problem right because I I do have
a Time
um constraint again I'm looking for the
move to happen sooner rather than later
you know if if I'm 15 minutes into the
trade I might break even most likely I
would
just re scratch it and try and scratch
it for either a small for even or maybe
a small profit or a small loss honestly
I I if I was doing it again this wasn't
I wasn't trading today I was out doing
Christmas shopping but looking back at
this you know I did want to talk about
it because it's easy to to look at a
chart and you know say oh yeah I could
have bought this and wrote it up
um me personally again that's me and
everybody trades differently I probably
would have just broken even
it did pull back again all the way to
three and three quarters before it
started ripping right it said this trade
took a bit longer than I would have
liked you know getting from getting in
around the 12 42 p.m
um before it finally started really
making that move around you know 20
minutes later just after one o'clock but
once it started making that move it
really picked up that head of steam you
know you get that late afternoon
um rally a lot of times in the equities
and you know from this was your entry
price you know way up here you know
trading up into the 08 09s you did pull
back down again towards nine and three
quarters before you ripped back up
all right and just you know trading
higher the rest of the
basically the rest of the the session so
again you know knowing yourself as a
Trader right and I know myself as a
Trader I I me personally I have a time
constraint
and
I'm looking for the move to happen
sooner rather than later but again not
everybody has that so again if you're if
you're looking to you know hold it
longer yeah you could have caught that
move but for me honestly I wouldn't have
caught that loop again people say well
why are you making these videos because
you know I I just want to show you
reasons for buying because there's going
to be times where this sort of sets up
and then it just rips in this case it
just sort of set up and then went
sideways for about 20 minutes before it
ripped to the upside
obviously the best moves are when they
happen just like this off of this low
instead of getting this this sideways
action before it rips up
so again hopefully you guys took away
some interesting things from this video
you know about looking for a low let the
order flow speak to you tell you what
it's happening in the market and you
know it's up to you again to put the
pieces together to understand that hey
you know what I could confidently buy
off this low I think this move can
keep going up because to be honest you
know anytime you're buying off a low the
potential Target is the existing high
and Beyond it you've seen a lot of times
where the markets make a new low then
rally off that low take out the high and
make new highs of the day it doesn't
happen always but that's the potential
that you do have
all right guys so I'll end the video
there and again if I don't talk to you
before Christmas have a nice Christmas
holiday
bye bye everyone